[Music]
Fiorella for four years Francisca
Schreiber was a close advisor to fry up
a tree former leader of the far-right
AFD party Schreiber has since left the
AFD and has warned about the party's
policies the AFD is the largest
opposition party in germany with 92
members in the German Bundestag your
book about this party is called inside
AFD do you see the party as a set of
high-density potiphar any sect it has a
sect like structure but in what way they
put up a united front everyone has to
stick together it's us against the world
against everyone else the media and
other political parties there's the AFD
and then there's the rest of society
they want to set themselves apart and
create their own society and that's a
strong sect like principle was that why
you joined the party it's us against the
rest of the world exactly it was this
notion of sticking together and working
together towards one primary goal it was
an exciting feeling at first made me
feel like I was in good hands it was
like a feel-good bubble you could be
attacked from all sides but it didn't
matter because the party sticks together
like a family
I thought that was really attractive
when I'm finished talking about
self-image it was grouped about in on
prices what was the big issue for you at
the beginning I liked the idea of
renewal a new political entity that
could break up the old political system
with more citizen involvement a sort of
bottom-up grassroots movement that's
what appealed to me from the start they
wanted to be more of a Citizens movement
and less of a typical political party
was talking to put a video online yes
how did the party change as a
distinguished started gradually right
from the start there were some
nationalists in the AFD it was a pretty
disparate
at first but it grew and grew they were
able to attract more nationalists and
those people also joined the party and
of course every time one of them made a
shocking statement the more liberal or
moderate members left the party
they all said this isn't why I joined so
I just doesn't miss me a focused oh that
stuff I didn't do the part I didn't you
were the party chair of the youth wing
of the AFD party in the state of Saxony
the youth wing chairman in Lower Saxony
has claimed that those who tried to
assassinate Hitler were traitors how
radical is the AF DS youth wing that's a
major problem this statement which has
since been rejected by the AFT leaders
is hardly an exceptional opinion among
youth wing members lots of them disgust
and say things like that behind closed
doors calling the anti-nazi resistance
traitors is a glorification of National
Socialism that's an ISIL is most social
and lessons without the positive and
you've made controversial statements
yourself in 2015 you said that denying
the Holocaust was simply testing the
limits of freedom of speech what I
actually said was that Holocaust deniers
used the speech restrictions to advance
their conspiracy theories back then I
thought that the restriction should be
lifted so that we could bring those
people out into the open and confront
them directly the middle and Lord of
hosts ethical rules I've never denied
the existence of the Holocaust zone from
Khan
it was deplorable in the Holocaust
allotment but at one point I did indeed
consider lifting the speech restrictions
so that people could express their
opinions openly and then be criticized
for them no one's done neighbor halls an
undeclared income is that still your
view no we have to consider the feelings
of the victims of National Socialism and
their families we simply cannot allow
people to make statements like that
it's one thing not to introduce such
restrictions in the first place and
quite another to lift them later if we
lifted the existing restrictions now it
would seem like we were somehow
condoning what people say so I
definitely do not support that position
today but I don't find myself a lady you
say that the AFD has become more
right-wing in the meantime nationalist
statements are appearing more often in
the media one referred to the Holocaust
Memorial in Berlin as a monument of
disgrace another said that the Nazi era
was just a blip on the timeline of
German history are these just verbal
slips that's all I know they are not at
first I thought they were like that
person was just misquoted or the remarks
were taken out of context but then I
realized that these statements were
deliberately made as provocations there
are lots of different reasons for that
for example a party official might have
been attacked by colleagues or perhaps
his career was on the brain Murray just
been reelected so he makes the
scandalous statement to appeal to the
grassroots supporters and if they're
hardcore they love it they see such
remarks as displays of courage and
standing up to the establishment in the
AFD it's quite common for people to make
radical comments and to prove to their
supporters that they haven't gone soft
supervised lists what's behind this
strategy don't they want the state
structure to stay like it is no
absolutely not the state structures make
sure that the AFD remains a minority
movement particularly in day-to-day
politics the AFD believes that the media
should be purged that's the way they put
it they say that all these grubby
leftist green and social democrat media
people should be tossed out so that they
can no longer influence what people
think
that is a and if that were to happen
people would see that the AFT is
actually the political party that
represents them best which substantially
increase their base of voters the
cosplay that's it sounds like the office
for the protection of the Constitution
should step end their job is to keep an
eye on extremists but in your book you
claimed that the director of that office
hans-georg Maassen advised former AFD
leader fry up a tree on how the party
could stay out of trouble for my team
what's your source for those allegations
Petri told me herself she also said that
beyond hiccup has senior party official
should be expelled to keep the
authorities from cracking down she said
she got her information from personal
conversations and told deputy party
leader alexander garland and several
other top officials about it garland
will confirm that the topic even came up
when the National AFD leaders held a
telephone conference and Paisley
discussed her consultations with Mawson
it's Petri claims that you made all of
this up and mr. malson denies that he
has ever advised the AFD some critics
have accused you of exaggerating your
importance within the party as part of
an effort to sell your book your
response
I think people overestimate the power of
a nonfiction book about politics I don't
think that a book written by someone who
used to be in the AFD is going to make
me rich even if there is a lot of
interest in the book I have no reason to
attack PT or Mawson that certainly
wasn't my intention Globo he said to gar
keine called Hitler and so class Noda
hates me and I did not part on bad terms
we had a good relationship right up to
the end we no longer have contact with
each other
but there's no ill will between us
Jesus is in de patata he said you joined
the party because of this
us-against-them constant but at what
point did you decide to quit us feeling
only lasts as long as you agree with
everything the party does but if you
start criticizing party policies then
you become a target
suddenly party members see you as part
of the establishment a member of the
Opposition a collaborator you experience
hostility and even hatred there were a
lot of insults I experienced that for
the first time when I criticized beyond
hecka about some of his racial theories
alt a wave of hatred washing over me
that was when I realized that people in
the AFD don't really stick together it's
all a facade mitten boohoo would you
describe your resignation from the party
as a positive development and if so
who's how it was really positive that I
was able to achieve closure by working
through what happened to me I could make
a clean break another positive messages
of support from people yes some say that
they felt uncomfortable about the party
but they blamed themselves now they said
they understand how the party works and
they decided to leave too or they won't
vote for the AFD again those messages
make me feel better
your sisters an anti-fascist are you two
talking again we never stopped but now I
think she enjoys talking to me and your
parents
yes they're certainly relieved that I
left the party they couldn't understand
why I joined in the first place
olsommer yeah I suppose they figured
that I'd eventually get to the point
where I couldn't take it anymore
I suppose it doesn't matter as our
interview draws to a close we'd like you
to complete three statements for us
first I helped to spread AFD propaganda
and I regret that because I brought
other people into the party in some
cases it ruins their lives and I truly
regret that for the Humber I wrote a
book about the AFD because viola and I
wanted closure and to get that I had to
work through everything that happened to
me a vote for the AFD is a vote for and
a party dominated by far-right radicals
Francisca Schreiber thank you thank you